francisco in nine days on the eighth
anniversary of the september 11th
attacks
those are some of the latest headlines
on c-span radio
washington journal continues
aaron arvidlen is the author of too good
to be true the rise and fall of bernie
madoff good morning thanks for joining
us thank you i'm going to share with you
one of the headlines this morning from
the washington post bernie madoff was
quote astonished that the sec never
caught him that's right i think
i think he expected to be caught long
before he was and what this ig report
the inspector general report shows is
that
it was a series of
almost keystone cop type of examinations
one hand didn't know what the other was
doing
and
and
at one point i think the the examiners
were given
his dtc number which is basically a
tracking agency showing where custody of
securities are they just never checked
the essence of the book can be found in
the summary i want to share with the
audience what you wrote the madoff
scandal transcends ethnicity religion
class and even international borders and
shows that even the savviest and most
intelligent people can be duped into
believing something that is too good to
be true
that's right um i i wrote that because i
wanted to make clear that this was not
specific to wall street wasn't specific
to the jewish community it wasn't
specific to wealthy people
or people of means
it filtered down
to all levels of america and all over
the globe
what did you learn
i learned first of all i was surprised
to learn that
a lot of people on wall street knew that
madoff was crooked they just didn't know
exactly how as far back as 2001 when i
wrote the original story for barron's
magazine
a lot of people knew that he was
doing something doing something that
that wasn't um
wasn't all there and but they were
afraid to stick their neck out well the
obvious question and based on this new
ig report in which one of the
conclusions that the sec never properly
examined or investigated the trading and
never took the necessary basic steps to
determine if madoff was operating a
ponzi scheme why
this is a question that i think
we're going to be asking for the ages
this is what
drove harry markopoulos i think
practically to distraction um
i think
it's a symptom of
the sec as an agency they hire a lot of
attorneys
they don't hire
wall street traders or
you know back office specialists and
it showed when they went to examine
madoff they didn't really even know what
to look for and then when they were
handed the evidence they didn't follow
up
let me ask you about ruth made off
because you're right ruth was a constant
presence she had worked with bernie
since the beginning when he borrowed
office space from her father and decades
later she still kept an office near her
husband in the lipsticks building 19th
floor you went on to say that ruth had a
penchant for secrecy
ruth madoff was a very smart lady and
she was with her husband from the very
beginning they operated out of her
father's
very successful accounting practice to
start
she had a head for numbers um i think of
her as sort of a lady macbeth figure
uh you know someone sort of as the power
behind the throne however the even the
madoff trustee has said there's not
enough evidence to indict her at least
not yet do you think she knew
uh
i'm i'm on the fence um
you know i think she was um she had a as
i said a head for figures she was the
bookkeeper for the legitimate broker
dealer business
and she also had an account with comad
which was the in internal marketing arm
so
she definitely knew there was a hedge
fund it's unclear whether she knew it
was a ponzi scheme more from the book
bernie as he was known to as investors
would manage your money and promise a
guaranteed 10 percent even 12 or higher
in an annual return as long as you
didn't ask any questions that's right uh
one of madoff's requests of his
investors
uh was that he basically extracted a
promise from you that you wouldn't tell
anyone he was managing your money
that was very unusual on wall street
especially people like to brag
so that was a
very distinct red flag
so with all of these red flags it goes
back to the basic question how he was
able to pull this off and for so long
yes um
in the book i talk a little bit with
a former sec
attorney
who's still in industry
and he said that
bernie madoff and his brother peter
madoff
really made themselves available to the
sec in starting in the late 70s
when congress mandated the sec to
deregulate stock trading they wanted to
break the monopoly of the new york stock
exchange
bernie madoff and his brother peter
basically went to the agency and said
we'll show you how to do it your agenda
is ours and as a result they were very
grateful to him and really revered him
you're right about chris cox the former
chair of the sec and the bush
administration that although the sec had
becoming
had
been becoming more bureaucratic and less
aggressive for some time under chairman
chris cox the sec morphed into a weak
defanged shell of itself
why is that
uh i think it came from the top
christopher cox had very little
experience in securities
and i think there was a reason for that
i think under the bush administration
essentially
the white house wanted a week's sec
and they got it
part of the sec's problems you say was
that it did not employ many people who
had been trained in finance or banking
those who knew how wall street ripped
people off instead you say the sec had
an odd tradition of hiring mostly
lawyers many very smart and competent
others just clocking time at the
government agency so they could then go
to work as wall street attorneys that's
right it's a revolving door
and sadly um
you know it's it's a way for
young securities lawyers to uh get some
experience um learn how the agency works
learn what it's looking for and then
go work for you know sometimes 10 or
more
times the money on wall street does
bernie madoff have a relationship with
his boys his children
uh
i don't believe so now but you know
everything about the madoff family is um
has to be viewed through the prism of
sort of think of it as like kabuki
theater
uh whereby
um we don't know if his confession was
staged to his sons we don't know
if the sun's new and
they're staying silent and saying they
have no relationship
so i i'm very
skeptical about that we've been reading
a lot about
the madoff homes including the home in
long island but he also had property in
france in palm beach and of course in
new york city where
where what's the status of these
properties uh the house in montauk in
long island is has just gone up for
auction
it's uh you know not a spectacular
mansion um maybe like you'd see in the
hamptons or um
you know say a mar-a-lago in palm beach
but uh it's ocean front property it's
very valuable um so to me that's the
most valuable part i also visited his
uh and ruth's house in palm beach it was
the old pulitzer family estate
also you know very very nice but very
subdued
and
he had a an apartment in captain tibbies
in france and
of course the penthouse apartment in
manhattan everything is up for sale
robert is joining us from winston-salem
north carolina good morning good morning
please
miss arvid line
uh steve i'd like to ask uh if we could
suggest a topic for a program and and
see what your thoughts are certainly
and
why not truth steve i mean to me that's
where we need to begin
i think that when if we deal with truth
all the other things just simply fall in
place i don't know how you see that
and as far as
a politician i think that
i call myself
an eisenhower democrat and and because
of the fact that
he obeyed the law
and i think that
we've gotten away from obeying the law
we think that because we are such such
that we can do
as we please
so so with regard to that of the bernie
madoff book how do you want to
characterize that i would like to ask
her mr verdon
how much fear was there
and i'll get off and listen to you guys
how much fear um you mean among the sec
uh are you still there he must have hung
up i would say um
in the report that came out earlier this
week the
agency
the inspector general talks a little bit
about
a young examiner who
said he really didn't want to pursue an
investigation one of the many into
madoff because he was a powerful
well-connected person
and i think madoff's position as
one-time chairman of nasdaq
also
maybe prevented
the sec from pushing further they just
couldn't believe that he would do
something like this ten years ago harry
mcropolis warned the sec about bernie
madoff who is he and why did they not
heed his warnings
so harry marcopoulos was a whistleblower
he testified in front of congress uh
several months ago explaining all the
warnings he had given to the sec
he started out as a business rival to
madoff
uh he was he and his boss were actually
looking into the strategy made off claim
to be using and he really was never
trading at all
anyway markopolis sent
letters to the
new england branch of the sec i think
ultimately that was forwarded to the new
york branch
but for various reasons including turf
wars
and as the ig's report shows and it's
available on the sec's website if anyone
wants to read it
it was again almost like the keystone
cops the left hand didn't know what the
right hand was doing in his warnings
which came back in 1999 also the year in
which congress repealed the
depression-era glass-steagall
legislation you wrote about that in the
book saying it kept commercial depositor
banks and investment banks separate
allowing the resulting supermarket of
financial institutions it was more
profitable for a bank to do business
with hedge funds instead of just
everyday lending against their
depositors accounts right so how did
that
correlate to what madoff was doing well
if in fact he'd been running a
legitimate hedge fund
i think it could have been a very
profitable business
but
the fact that he was able to go on for
so long i think was part of the larger
hedge fund mania
which
really took off with the bull market of
19 the 1990s through i guess the
financial crisis in september 2007.
hedge funds have become a real force on
wall street they account for a huge
amount of the trading volume
and
i think madoff was seen as one of these
billion dollar funds among many others
and for that reason
perhaps he wasn't
as scrutinized as much
but
under uh the obama administration hedge
funds will have to register if they're
larger than 30 million dollars in assets
at least if the if that part of the bill
passes what motivated bernie madoff
uh i wish i knew
i think
i think he
got a rush out of getting away with it
i think also
you know he liked
giving wealthy people or people of means
what they wanted which was
good returns consistent returns
and as a result he was able to travel in
very elite circles
loretta is joining us from cleveland
good morning
oh good morning good morning steve good
morning miss erwin thank you
um
i know the question is being asked how
did he get away with this for so long
and i think that this goes
straight
to the fact that
he's white
he has privilege he has prestige
and he's plugged into the good old boy
network
that puts
greed and profits
over obeying the law
and we have seen this
run a muck ever since
uh bush came into office we have it with
enron we have it with um the
communications company i can't think of
the name of it right now
yeah yeah
you can look straight down the line and
you can see
all of these people that made
gazillions of dollars and they're not
being looked at to see whether they
obeyed the law in order to make those
profits
which was one of the conclusions from
the inspector general that's right
i wish i could just disagree with lauren
but i i think she's exactly right
you know the question is
whether more regulation is required or
not
sometimes i'm on the fence about it i
think
more regulation can hurt the small
advisor and
i think if the rules had been enforced
and in fact the sec had done its job in
the first place in fact in this report
the inspector general says the sec could
have caught made off in 1992
so i think the rules were in place they
just weren't being followed our guest is
aaron arville and the book is called too
good to be true the rise and fall of
bernie madoff and your first
piece on bernie madoff came eight years
ago correct right it was a story for
barron's magazine it was written in 2001
i got a tip from a very good source of
mine um
his name is ken nakayama he was then
working at deutsche bank
and
he pointed me to one of these feeder
funds or you know fund of hedge funds
they're sometimes called
which it turned out was the underlying
portfolio was being run by bernie madoff
have you ever met bernie madoff no i
interviewed him on the phone
and
i only spoke with him for about 10
minutes
do you remember the conversation i do
i actually had uh been working on the
story for a while and i was trying to
gin up as much information as i could
about him
people were very reluctant to talk on
the record
in part because they were worried about
getting kicked out of madoff's you know
supposed hedge fund
uh finally
um about a day or two before the baron
story was supposed to run
i told them i spoke to someone at his
firm and i explained that it was going
to run regardless
and then suddenly he was made available
he was apparently overseas he said he
was in switzerland
maybe on a boat so but he really didn't
tell me much she just said it's a
proprietary strategy i can't go into it
our next call is michael from asheville
north carolina good morning
hey good morning
mike here i was curious when this whole
thing broke last year about where were
the regulators and then
the next question was for the regulators
of the regulators
where was the
senate finance committee under both
democrats and republicans and likewise
the
house
financial services committee under
democrats and republicans and
i happen to be one of those small
advisors
and it seems like every time something
like this happens i get five more pieces
of paper
to fill out for the poor guy that wants
to put 50 bucks down a month on his kids
529 plan i'll ring off and
take
my answer on the line
i
i sympathize um
i think in
in most cases the sec prefers to go
after the little guy because it's easier
um i mean clearly in the report even i
think one of the examiners says
he he or she didn't want to
go through the madoff trading records
because it would take a ton of time
well that's
that's the nature of these exams
and i think
as a result i really hope that the small
advisors
don't suffer because
you know they're not the ones who pulled
off the billion dollar ponzi scheme our
guest is written for the new york times
barons moscow times and dow jones
newswire she's a graduate of tufts
university a comment from one viewer who
says what motivated madoff is the same
thing that motivated his investors greed
no
i i would agree
for those people who knew that they were
investing with madoff um
there were many there were many people
who put their money directly in with
madoff and
perhaps in their heart of hearts
knew that
the returns were far too consistent and
he couldn't lose money that that's again
too good to be true which is why we
picked the name for the book
um but then there were also many people
who came in indirectly
you know through feeder funds or
through a retirement plan
these people had no clue that madoff was
the portfolio manager so in their case
i don't think we can blame greed i just
think that uh there was
very little disclosure
and he contends in his uh
not testimony but when he uh pled guilty
that the money went to a bank he'd never
invested any of it is that what you've
heard as well that's correct um the
money
bainoff had a bank account at jpmorgan
chase
it was essentially a cash in cash out
operation
investors would send him a check
and he would pay out of redemption from
this account
he never made any trades and this is why
it was so astonishing i guess as he even
made off said that he was never caught
it would have been very easy to go check
with
uh nasdaq or with the depository and
trust corporation but
uh no one from the sec did you write
that madoff's london office also played
a large role in helping to hide his
fraud london may have started out
legitimate but over the decades it
morphed into a financial outpost for the
madoff family a place where they felt
comfortable stashing what they
considered their personal fortune
roughly 113 million pounds by the year
2008 which is about 220 million in us
dollars that's correct um
london was
an office that madoff opened in the
mid-80s
and it did start out as a place where he
and his legitimate broker-dealer could
trade stocks overnight
back in the 80s even it wasn't that
common uh to trade you know as we do 24
hours a day um
so
anyway
by
mid 2000s
probably 2007 and 2008
the madoffs were starting to wire money
back and forth to
make it look as if there were trades
they were also paying for yachts
peter madoff bought an aston martin
through london
so it was really just sort of a family
bank account tom from gross island
michigan with aaron arvindland good
morning you're on the air hi hi good
morning steve uh you found your niche in
life first of all you're excellent at
what you do hi aaron hi good morning
uh there's a couple of things that
that i wonder if they're loosely
connected and that would be the
disappearance here in detroit of detroit
national bank of detroit a very
conservative
well-run bank taking over in the 90s
after this i believe regarding this
deregulation
uh taken over by this uh
wildcatters kind of from uh columbus
ohio which i really despised who took
them over uh they were taken over by the
the bunch they were called bank one
and uh they they failed because they uh
we're here to pedal credit cards but
then we have the collapse of long-term
capital management in 99 which they said
if they didn't bail them out the world
economy would collapse and i i sat there
slack jawed on on comprehending what
they were talking about and then we have
things like the society general in
france the stealing of seven billion
dollars
and the ubs uh moving fifty thousand was
it the clients offshore
and is this all connected in some
general way uh
could you comment in any way on that
sure um
i can't speak to uh bank one i can say
that the long-term capital management uh
set a precedent in terms of bailouts of
wall street
um
i mean i think ltcm uh that bailout made
the bail out of aig and you know some of
the other firms that we've seen more
palatable at least
i think it's a scandal nevertheless but
in terms of
ubs i can't say for certain whether
there's a connection but i do believe
that
it's become harder and harder for
investors to hide money offshore and i
think the
the ubs accounts
are going to
really again set a precedent
for u.s investors in hedge funds or
in offshore accounts you wrote about
this being or it's been written as a 65
billion dollar ponzi scheme you say that
that basically was 65 billion dollars on
paper there never was 65 billion that's
correct can you elaborate
so uh working backwards from 65 billion
um
let's assume for argument's sake that
madoff was uh claiming 10 gains a year
and um phantom gains as we now know
false profits
i believe that the
ponzi began from the very beginning
perhaps in a smaller scale but beginning
being one year meaning in the 1960s
so if we assume that
he was reporting an average of 10
percent a year gains over a period of 30
or 40 years
then
the actual dollar amount if you take
away all the the profits is somewhere
between 12 and 20 billion
that's the actual dollars that went in
now where did all the money go um
roughly half of the 12 to 20 probably
came from these fund of hedge funds
and those are the billion dollar funds
that we've been reading about that are
being sued either by uh federal
prosecutors or the madoff trustee to uh
give the money back
um so that brings us to
say six to ten billion that's still
still uh missing
there are a number of individual
investors among them stanley chase and
jeffrey pickauer who have
also been
sued by the madoff trustee for allegedly
taking out more than they put in
these are the people who
the trustee alleges were the big
beneficiaries and they probably account
for between one and five
so
there's a very good possibility that
there's some money offshore
i think that's that's what the madoff
trustee is going to be looking for next
our guest is aaron arvalen the book is
too good to be true the rise and fall of
bernie madoff and jim is joining us from
new york city good morning jim yes good
morning uh i'm going to make a statement
first and then ask a question a friend
of mine
had his money invested in madoff and he
showed me his statements
and after looking at the statements the
first thing that stood out in my mind
was the auditor nobody but anyone ever
heard of this auditor before that's the
thing that surprised me the most about
it uh a way one way i think he got away
with getting these people in there's an
old uh old jewish statement i've lived
in this city for 40 years and i'm jewish
it used to be an old thing like i can
get it for your wholesale
and a lot of people
he used that trick uh you know
i got my friend bernie he's doing a
wonderful job for me let me call bernie
of his people and get you in the fun and
that's how he got a lot of these people
it wasn't and and one of the my question
is this hey before you ask your question
without um revealing any of the secrets
with your friend how much money did he
lose and what has he said since the
confession and now his imprisonment um
he's not happy about it but lucky for
him he wasn't totally invested in the
man he had he's not going to lose his
house he's not going to lose a lot of
things but he's going to lose
uh he's gonna lose a few million i think
that's my guess at it i mean i didn't go
that far into him i looked at the
statements sure but that the thing that
stood out in my mind i said this who's
this auditor i've never heard this
you're gonna ask a question so go ahead
uh my question to you is um
i don't like hedge funds and i think a
lot of them are just basically
manipulators of stock but it's my
understanding mr donaldson wanted to try
to regulate them years ago but it was
the statement is and answering this
question they said there's a federal law
that would not allow the securities and
exchange commission to regulate them
there's a law out there uh there's a
bill under consideration as part of this
larger financial reform package that
president obama would like to push
through
and under that
uh hedge funds
or
advisors of 30 million or more would be
required to register with the sec
how then they would be that would be
enforced is still i think to be to be
decided because both the sec and finra
would like um
their their their own purview over hedge
funds so
this could set us up for another turf
battle between agencies
so
anyway
but yes they they should be if this bill
passes they could very well be regulated
by the way if you're interested in
reading the full report from the
inspector general it's available online
at csbn.org
and an email from a viewer who says
seems like the corruption runs into the
governing agency how cozy is the
relationship between the sec and the
traitors
ah such a good question um
there were reports for instance that
some of the young examiners
who went to madoff's offices over you
know this period of it looks like
15 or 16 years
would leave their resumes on the way out
currently the relationship between the
sec and wall street is incredibly cozy
in part because wall street recruits
from the agency
there's no rule you know say a statute
of limitations on working at the agency
that prevents you from going to straight
to wall street
um it's it's a problem with this other
email from a viewer in salt lake city
utah saying can the author tell me why
the obama administration has not hired
mr markopoulos in some capacity i heard
him testify on c-span very impressed and
sickened by the inaction of the
securities and exchange commission
yes that was uh that was riveting um
actually i believe one of the
congressmen offered the job of chief
whistleblower to mr markopoulos and as
far as i know he hasn't accepted um he
in his in his own words has said he
likes chasing bad guys he's a certified
fraud examiner which essentially means
that he
will go after frauds against the us
government
and
i think reaps some sort of
compensation for that
chairman shapiro mary shapiro has talked
about um setting up a similar program
with the sec and i think that that's one
of the reforms under consideration by
the way if you're navigating on our
website and looking for that inspector
general report you'll find it under
featured links and we'll keep it there
if you want to read specific details the
story this morning front page in the
washington post inside the business
section
their report in the failings of the sec
in the bernie madoff investigation
gerald is joining us from tucson arizona
good morning republican line good
morning
in my three score years in six i've seen
multiple scandals such as this
and the inspector general report talks
about incompetence and they talk about
pure laziness
uh also in my three score years and six
i've seen almost no one held accountable
is there going to be any accountability
for these so-called and i put that in
quote civil servants
who
really uh created havoc in these
investors lives i'll hang up and listen
to the answer thank you thank you and
just to augment what gerald was saying
the story this morning the business
section of the new york times how the
sec
missed many red flags in their
investigation so to his point will
anyone be held accountable uh
i haven't heard of any
for instance any sec lawyers or
examiners for instance
going to jail
um i also
would love to know whether the sec still
has sovereign immunity i believe they do
actually um although there are some made
of investors who are actually suing
finra
which is the successor agency to the
nasd
and i wonder also if any of them might
go after you know some of the previous
uh
chairman of the sec
our next call is gene from los angeles
good morning welcome to the program
democrats line uh good morning um
i get nervous so i'm gonna plug through
this really quickly well don't don't be
nervous we're glad to hear from you and
the forum is yours so go ahead with your
comment question um first of all you're
all heroes at c-span um second of all
um there's uh if you go to google and
you put in madoff double bluff there's a
very interesting article um he
um
talks about uh the legitimacy of people
who invested in the fund we'll try to
pull it up what is it what's the google
search and we'll pull it up right now
uh yes uh made off double bluff double
double bluff okay okay but now the other
thing that i think is important is and
these are questions maybe they were
looked into
um
the
i understand there's going to be tax
write-offs for the investors that will
allow them to write off three years back
and 20 years forward
that those will be based on pre-economic
collapse dollars i recognize that some
of the um
funds or the money was phantom
and then also um there is insurance for
many of the people
lloyd's london etc and then i understand
there's also an sec fund
and i'm wondering um
what you've looked into in that regard
and also one other issue was um
i think in that article he talks about a
lot of people who invested in the fund
knowing that it was
uh not on the up and up felt that the
government would come in and take over
or would um compensate people in that
um the sec was ultimately responsible
we'll get a response that wasn't so bad
was it no need to be nervous
gonna phone in again okay all right
thank you thank you
so to answer gene's uh your last
question gene um there is a civic fund
securities investor protection
uh corporation their their
maximum i believe per investor is 500
000
currently the main off trustee is
administering um
the number of claims coming in
and uh i think that numbers so far about
roughly one and a half to two billion
he hasn't paid out as much
i believe if you look on the madoff
trustee website you can see that he's
set up sort of an informal deadline
running through the end of this year
which explains
how many claims he expects to pay out
and as far as
long-term capital again i think that set
the precedent for expectations that
hedge fund investors would get bailed
out dan is one of the regulars who
tweets us here on c-span he says yes i
all i see is wall street making big
money
the only numbers we should see from them
their prison number
you write in the book in the year
leading up to madoff's confession
investors started to panic and withdrew
12 billion dollars out of the accounts
at the firm about 6 billion was taken
out just three months before the
financier was arrested back in december
and then you say had the stock market in
the u.s not collapsed made off and his
scam probably would have continued right
uh the stock market collapse is what
really unraveled madoff
everybody came to uh bernie madoff at
the same time because he was the only
one
supposedly not losing money um
i don't know if your 401k is um anything
like it was two or three years ago but
uh
you know if you're losing an investment
elsewhere you're gonna go um to where
you can always get your cash out but it
just wasn't there i think some are now
calling them 201 so go to sean in
vancouver washington good morning you're
on the air good morning miss arvalon a
front-running front-running front
running the reason markopolis was
ignored was that there is the
gentleman's agreement on wall street
that the market makers and specialists
all front run the tape
everyone was willing to look the other
way with bernie because everyone else
was in on it in 2004 the sec reached a
settlement with the specialists and they
had to pay something like 200 million
dollars which was nothing compared to
what they've been stealing from the
american people all these years bernie
madoff started off as a market maker and
even the market makers on the nasdaq got
busted in the 1990s and still they were
able to settle and
these people these wall street pigs
are intellectual and ethical bankrupts
your worst suspicions about these people
don't come close to the criminality and
and
psychotic nature of these people
front running it's all front running the
tape could you address that thanks sure
um this is the initial suspicion uh that
madoff was front-running his clients
that was part of the reason why
a lot of hedge funds wouldn't do
business with him because they thought
he was front-running is when a broker
steps in front of his customer his or
her customer's orders
and
so that was my suspicion
back in
2001
the inspector general's report as
outlined by uh you know a couple of
different papers today
showed that that's what the sec was
looking for but they never addressed
harry markopoulos's claim that madoff
was running a ponzi scheme in fact they
didn't even know about the entire floor
in his business
that was you know the supposed hedge
fund
another uh tweet where is bernie madoff
being held he's down in uh prison in
butner north carolina
and he's uh currently serving 150 year
sentence from the washington post the
inspector general's report concludes
that the agency's failings were a result
of misjudgment not improprieties
uh that's putting it kindly um
i i have no particular beef with the sec
i know they try and do their jobs just
like everyone else but
it's it's embarrassing when you read
this inspector general's report and this
is only the executive summary the full
450 page
report from the inspector general hasn't
come out yet i'm i can't wait to read it
uh so
yes harry markopoulos said the same
thing he testified in front of congress
and said
you know the sec is incompetent
maybe not corrupt but definitely
incompetent our guest is aaron arvadlin
our next call is michelle from
tallahassee good morning
good morning
uh i've got a couple of questions when
is the
sec
implemented and what congress and
administration actually
uh assisted with setting up the sec
and uh if a ponzi scheme correct me if
i'm wrong is basically you know where
you're collecting money and you don't
really have any dividends you're not
making any money but you take future
investments and that's kind of how you
pay your dividends off if that's correct
then that would be and he started in the
60s and that would be about the same
time that social security was taken off
of being locked down and so therefore
social security would be the largest
ponzi scheme of them all well first on
the creation of the sec in the 1930s
sure um my understanding was that it was
set up to correct some of the abuses of
the great crash of 1929
and
among others ferdinand pacora us had a
commission that helped to
question some of the big wall street
bankers and he was one of the ones i
quote in the book
talking about how to correct some of the
abuses on wall street
as for your second question i've i've
read this in many other places comparing
madoff's ponzi scheme to that of social
security
so
ponzi schemes are are pretty basic it's
just a pyramid scheme whereby
early investors put their money in and
their money is used to pay later
investors and
money always has to keep coming in
in order to pay people off
and uh and where does the name ponzi
come ponzi comes from charles ponzi he
set up one of these original scams in
america anyway um in the 1920s but his
was using um postage stamps so um
how did that work i i believe he was uh
selling postage stamps
overseas and he said that he could make
50 or 100 investment in 30 days
so um again if the returns were just too
good to be true in madoff's case the
returns were
maybe upwards of 10 a year
but um he never lost money and that was
just impossible which is the title of
the book too good to be true our guest
is the author and tommy from nashville
is next good morning
good morning steve good morning uh
america and thanks for c-span uh you
might want to get your pencil
uh i've got a couple of good points here
okay can we take one at a time
okay one at a time is um the uh
deregulation of the markets
and and uh what mccain and uh bill
graham
and the repelling of glass-steagall you
just mentioned the
clash of 29 how much that was a
and that law that the fellow caller
called before that was a 2000 while pass
and it was where where it was
against allowed to even look at these
hedge funds okay let's take that point
we'll come up with the follow-up sure um
i know what he's referring to um
actually i think it was the uh capital
markets um modernization act of 2000 but
um i'd have to double check it
but uh the point was that um there was a
there was a period um
during the
dot-com boom and um i guess subsequent
in the bust
where
congress tried to legislate um
derivatives
and also
there was a push under
chairman donaldson which one of the
earlier callers mentioned to regulate
hedge funds
it never went anywhere um
and i think once the market recovered in
2002 and 2003 when people are making
money they're less apt to ask questions
and ask for regulation and i think all
of that has come home to roost tommy
follow up all right my follow-up is uh
during the deregulation time also
uh to the best of my knowledge in
absorption absorption of the facts is
the defunding of the scc also
and the changing of the uptick rule
right that's true i think the the sec
has finally um made a ruling on on the
uh the uptick they reinstated it as i
unders as i understand um
but uh
you know look there are always calls for
federal agencies to get more money and
more staff and better training and i
think in the sec's case
they really deserve it
however
you know again if you read this uh
inspector general report it seems as if
they if they had just done what they
were supposed to do
madoff might have been caught a lot
earlier who is eric swanson
eric swanson was
an attorney with the sec
he was
involved in one of the exam early
examinations i believe it was in the
2004-2005 period
he ultimately became romantically
involved with bernie madoff's niece
shauna madoff and they got married in
2007.
he um there were some questions about
whether or not he influenced the sec
to not look so closely this actually
clears his name
so
anyway that's that's who eric swanson is
libby joining us from the cape edgarton
massachusetts good morning good morning
i apologize i have terrible call but
i've been fascinated listening to this
um i do know families here in
new england that were wiped out
um by madoff are a good part of their
equity was wiped out
um the questions that i have are
in terms of the sec
i think it's grossly unfair
to try to put the blame on the federal
employees the brain belongs on every one
of the political appointees that were
put in
and i know this for a fact because i
came out of a mess called bayou
investment
chris cox when he was put in there the
former congressman from california was
told by the administration the burj
cheney administration not to do any type
of investigative work
i happen to know career employees
who are married to friends of mine from
childhood who said that basically all
they could do was um do busy work
for the last eight years and then prior
to that when the republicans had control
of the congress and that's why harry um
um
what is his name
who is absolutely the white knight that
rode in was dismissed he was considered
a quack he was considered a goof ball
and every edit a basic nuisance to the
sec right now and you know something
this is all of a part
bernie made up
is a thief he is a ghana in in yiddish
and to tell
for anybody to say that his wife and his
kids his brother-in-law knew nothing is
absolutely beyond belief libby will stop
you on that point appreciate the call
i'll just uh say to libby that um yeah i
think the mayor harry mcauliffe said it
right he said the sec
especially the lower level employees
were discouraged from making big cases
we've been watching this video and it's
been on youtube as he was making his way
to court for his initial court
appearance where he pled guilty and then
subsequently appeared for his uh
sentencing
what kind of a person was bernie madoff
and what social network did he have in
new york yeah
bernie madoff and his wife came from uh
pretty humble roots they came from a
middle class neighborhood in queens
laurelton
um
went to public schools and
public universities
but i would say by the 1980s as a result
of his legitimate business
madoff was making millions of dollars a
year he had a very successful trading
operation again his legitimate business
and was meanwhile running this
phony hedge fund on the side
this really vaulted
the madoffs into
high society particularly in new york in
palm beach
and
in london
but you know madoff was a very private
person he kept people at bay in part um
to cultivate that
velvet rope as it were
the idea that he was a vip and that was
really part of the marketing of his
hedge fund this tweet from raul
mccartney saying besides bernie who
actually made money off of his business
who were the big players sure
um i mentioned to earlier um the made
electricity is alleging that um
one by the name of jeffrey pickauer took
out roughly uh that he believes five
billion dollars over the years
so that would have been much more very
likely than he put in and the way that
um
he was able to do that allegedly was
that madoff would just write down on
paper
a made-up gain or loss so for instance
i believe pick our received or perhaps
it was stanley chase who raised a lot of
money in hollywood for madoff
received upwards of 900 percent one year
um so
once um
once these investors were able to reap
these kinds of gains and oftentimes
order up losses
um
so that they didn't have to pay taxes
our next call is from surprise arizona
ronnie sue is on the phone good morning
hi good morning good morning aaron how
are you hi ronnie sue
um i have a question in light of the sec
report that came out yesterday
which obviously
puts a lot of doubt
in a lot of victims minds and i am a
madoff victim
it made us
realize that maybe we need to look into
other
regulatory agencies that should have
some responsibility
and as such we
contacted finra a few weeks ago and
asked them for
an accounting of their investments
to date we haven't heard anything um
just
this past week we found out that there's
another
a complaint issued against finra by
merivet securities
and in that complaint they mentioned
that they believe that
the investment portfolio of
uh finra was invested with bernard
madoff that's correct caller can i go
back to something earlier though you
said that you were a victim as well
yes i am how so
um i invested with bernie madoff for
probably more than half my life about 30
years
and lost everything that i have and i'm
actually involved with a group of other
victims bernardmade or victims.org
is a website where victims we have 400
victims that have come together
to try to find justice and restitution
and why did you invest with him
i invested with him because he was rock
solid he was known to be
a pillar of wall street and
i i had seen other people that had
invested with him and were successfully
withdrawing money it wasn't a black hole
that the money went into
and um we researched him we did our
homework
and there was absolutely nothing wrong
with this man
let me read an excerpt from aaron
arvalen's book and get your reaction she
wrote that it was this high level of
trust that led smart and savvy people
especially in the jewish community to
invest with madoff over the ensuing
years without asking serious questions
and they were not driven by greed but
rather by the desire to invest in their
futures with someone they felt they
could trust
do you agree with that
well it was trust but it was trust
instilled by the sec
so it wasn't um
you know i think it crosses all
boundaries of ethnicity and age and
demographics um
when
the very agency that's put in place to
tell us that our investments are safe
does so
you know that possible boundaries
yeah and how much did you lose if i may
ask
um you know i used to say that i've been
pretty visible um in the media and i
used to say that and and i think at this
point i i've changed my my mo and i
think just to say that i lost every
penny that i've ever had
um
every
asset that i had went in tomato if we
sold a house about four years ago and
all that money went into madoff so
when you lose ten thousand dollars and
that's everything you have or whether
you lose 10 million and that's
everything you have and you're left with
zero it doesn't matter where you started
from
ronnie sue thank you for the call from
arizona um i'd like to uh you know make
a comment about um the suit that ronnie
sue mentioned um it was filed i believe
a few weeks ago and it's um
the suit is alleging that finra which
was the successor to the nisd
um
has they have their own investment
portfolio and that at some point in the
past i don't know exactly when uh but
that the agency finra may have actually
had investment money with madoff
um so it's something that's going to be
coming out in the courts we're going to
go to george next from personalville
virginia good morning you're on the air
with aaron arvillen
okay thank you very much um
great to have a great book question
about chris cox how long was he there
and didn't have heart surgery so he
really wasn't on the job for part of the
time i don't know and the other one is
when arthur levitt was there he tried to
make changes
and congress republicans and democrats
both shot him down
this is true um i don't know exactly how
many years cox was at the agency but um
he he really was considered a very
laissez faire uh chairman of the sec
and as far as arthur levitt
you know he actually his his career
dated back to um bernie's career they
were they were contemporaries um and
they knew of each other and i believe
arthur levitt has even said you know he
was shocked to find out that bernie
madoff had done this
um it's uh i mean it's it's the fact
that until mary shapiro has come into
office
really no sec chairman has had him has
had a mandate to make serious changes
and i really hope that she's able to do
that mary is joining us from houston
good morning welcome to the program
thank you sp c-span i would like to
comment on this
question how did the regulators miss
this
i'm an administrative lawyer
in a privately owned
heavily regulated industry here in
houston
and i see a mega trend
of the regulators
really regulating heavily the good
citizens
and doing inspections and reports and
lots of make work
for people who have no complaints
yet in our own industry
we have some real bad actors
and they never closed in on them
uh they beat up good citizens
all day every day for
minor paper infractions
but they're not doing the real job so
i don't think this is a surprise
i think when you start regulating
everybody
then you're gonna you're gonna miss
the main task which is to go after the
bad actors
uh this is this is another um
a vote for a whistleblower program
especially one that compensates the
whistleblowers particularly on wall
street
i
totally agree with you and
you know more regulation is not going to
help
the small advisors and the people who
are doing their jobs correctly and
honestly
from the financial times uh again a
quote from the headline this morning
from the inspector general's report that
officials approached mr madoff in some
of his financial dealings and the staff
the sec staff accepted his seemingly
impossible explanations at face value
was there no follow-up
no
there was none i mean i i was reading
this inspector general's report which
as you mentioned is on c-span's website
they themselves say
it's it's shocking
how the
the examiners had
the time and they had the capability of
doing the follow-up and they just didn't
do it
our next call is david from crofton
maryland good morning
yes good morning i was wondering if
you're aware of any connection between
elliot spitzer being targeted by the sec
and the fbi
because he was investigating madoff and
other people on wall street
he was actually investigating the mutual
fund industry and in fact in this report
the sec
inspector general mentions how every i
believe roughly in 2003 2004
most many of the agencies staff was
asked to turn their attention to mutual
funds i think that was in response to
spitzer's investigation
and
spitzer also raised a lot of money from
hedge funds um
he pretty much left them alone
left most of hedge funds on wall street
alone and i think that was
in part because he chose to go after the
mutual fund timing scandal one final
point from the book you say that the
madoff scandal was the product of
several bubbles the bubble in hedge
funds in housing prices in credit cards
in americans living beyond their means
uh you know the hedge fund industry was
um probably i would say 50 funds
sometime starting in the 1980s and
perhaps 500 million dollars
by 2007
i believe that number was 2 trillion
dollars in assets it's still nowhere
near the mutual fund industry but it's
certainly growing
since the market collapsed hedge funds
now run about 1.4 trillion i think is
the is the number um maybe 15 to 20
percent of them have closed um it's
still an enormous industry and i think
uh hedge funds are where mutual funds
were say 20 or 25 years ago they're
going to be with us so after researching
bernie madoff and looking into this case
what are the lessons
uh
check who has custody of your assets um
go back to your portfolio manager and
ask um
you know who's who's touching my money
who has control over the decisions
are there you know independent third
parties
making sure that no one can use make
transactions on my behalf
madoff had custody of all his investors
money and
that's very unusual
the book is called too good to be true
the rise and fall of bernie madoff our
guest aaron arvindlin the author thanks
very much for joining us thank you steve
please come back again i will
coming up in just a moment live at the
berkins institution vice president biden
asking for the ability to speak to
brookings about the stimulus spending he
will be introduced by strobe talbot
formerly with the clinton administration
the topic of the speech is reinventing
the reinvestment act and its impact on
the u.s economy the vice president will
be starting momentarily again a reminder
that if you want to read more from the
inspector general report you can log on
to our website at cspan.org and click
under featured links and you can read
the entire report and the interview that
we just conducted with aaron overland
will also be available online at
cspan.org we're back tomorrow morning
for c-span's washington journal and on
our programming tomorrow a preview of
the supreme court oral arguments that
will take place next wednesday looking
at a movie
focusing on hillary clinton and its
impact on the 2008 campaign an early
start for the u.s supreme court they
will begin the formal term in
the first monday of october and one
other reminder that our new documentary
on the supreme court will premiere the
first sunday of october here on c-span
thanks for being with us on this
thursday morning enjoy the rest